I'm in charge of the support for the operational aspect
Correct
. I'll leave command on the ground to Delphinium on the leader plane. No, why is he the leader?
Stay calm and lively Concentrate on your partner's behavior and
surrender yourself
Then, connect,
collect me, I'm tired It's a little bit of a gap between our hearts, and my stomach capacity is big
It's important to trust and accept your partner,
Yukiko It's okay
[Music]
I wasn't
good at it, it's a good feeling We're not good at it, but it's okay.
Tokeya I'm fine
Dive into the future
Mayo c Darayo 4th
me It
's okay
That was that
Mr. Moto has the pilot type and he's taking it, so I wonder if the girl who's connected to Mr. Blank will file a lawsuit
Think about it
big loss
Kato  I'm good at exiles and all kinds [music] yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah